that was the craziest play what do you
got there Ryan steak and eggs steak and
eggs that's breakfast stay connected
breakfast things with breakfast which is
an arrogant brat Wow not a Canadian
breakfast thing go make an impact guys
make an impact now
all right super excited I am heading off
to New York for 24 hours to go meet Ryan
Holliday he's the author of tons of
books he's an expert on book marketing
we're going to do a top 10 video on him
which is the first time we've done a top
10 with the person being in the top time
super cool and I'm going to meet with a
bunch of fans in New York but before
that I have to clean up I folded all the
clothes because i don't want needed to
come home to a messy house so it cleaned
up put a bunch of stuff away I stuff to
go do I'm going to try to clean the
dishes are going to come home in 20
minutes quickly do the dishes and then
get ready to go to New York I want to
get a part of it you know the new york
new york one of the things that I love
doing is leaving some notes for Nina
want to go away so under her pillow
she's gonna open flipped over just gonna
see
you gotta always do some surprises for
the wife
all right let me show you what I'm
packing it's only 24 hours it's not a
big deal i'm generally light packer
anyway i never check my luggage if i can
add all avoid it so i'm traveling with
my backpack i'm wearing a hoodie i'll
bring an extra hoodie it's raining swiss
terrain in New York so I got to be
prepared for that I'm going to bring my
camera bag and I'll wear this wear this
around me and then my backpack got the
laptop will put the ipad in there too
I've got my tripod sitting here
toothbrush plugs change of clothes in
here I've got my plugs and then I went
the whole foods and I bought a pack of
12 of these fermented vegan protein
things we'll see they're not that bad
just so if I'm in a rush I'm not eating
a bunch of crap and then in final pocket
two of the books from Ryan Holliday that
I haven't read yet so I got some reading
to do on the plane that's it one
backpack camera bag good to go Nina just
wrote this here that she's on her way
she's gonna pick me up take him to the
airport New York baby Nina came home
Nina's planting stuff on our window so
what are these cucumber and shirt all
right we're late we're late we're late
are we late yes we're late gotta go
I'm going to miss you forever forever
and ever forever and ever and ever and
ever okay there we go here we go
the guy at the check-in security her
time at the 40 pastor [ __ ] on my iPad
with one on a phone the ipad is too big
and device come on people
two different device anyway I'm gonna
get some boost to juice go to my gate
normal this time I'd be checking email
messaging people catching up on work but
I'm going to meet Ryan holiday tomorrow
so I got his book you gave it to me not
that long ago god this book see what it
says right on it and I'm gonna just then
I haven't done for a long time which is
actually just sit at an airport and sit
on the plane and read paperback book
usually lost my devices some house
obviously a fun experience it's thick
ish I don't know if I'm going to be able
to greet all that by tomorrow but we'll
see who's i'll have more contacts when I
meet so it looks like our flight is
delayed associate we at the hotel by
ten-thirty and I put out a call and my
newsletter list to see anyone from meet
up with me and Arturo we've been on my
channel a couple times off to pick me up
at the airport I'm at the hotel just
super nice and that was going to meet up
with four or five other entrepreneurs
for my list on 1030 at the hotel in the
lobby but I just had the right to cancel
them it's probably gonna be too late now
tomorrow morning a meeting with ryan and
then
some other entrepreneurs in the
afternoon so kind of bums me out that I
have to cancel on the subscribers as
part of the best part for me four
chaplains meeting with guys who are fans
of the channel fans with newsletter but
don't want to keep them up you know if i
get in at midnight it's kind of like to
have a meeting so we'll see all right I
gotta stretch a little bit legs are
getting tired gotta refresh the mind
gotta manage a little bit win 03 with
your muah take a walk back up [ __ ]
juice dinner dinner drink number two
while I wait time to board very exciting
I have to cancel on Arturo to you
couldn't make the late to pick up so I
cabinet I'm going to just hang by myself
tonight it's very sad but excited a
small plane and just excited to get to
New York here we go
all right around the airport and 30
first thing you do when you land this
message the wife and tell her that you
landed and you love her
alright finally made it longest cap
right ever costs me sixty dollars but
I'm here ready the chuckit 505 here we
go you can never be too safe got a nice
bad TV closet bathroom nice so get on
the internet say hi Vanina check-in
let's see this is we have an
entrepreneur conversations have a shower
have a shower wake up tomorrow and go
see Ryan Holliday
good morning good morning good morning
good morning good morning interesting
night fell asleep around two-thirty woke
up around 5 45 not used to the streets
of New York and the the noise pollution
but doesn't matter super excited had a
shower ready to go I think there's an
important announcement to make this is
my youtube channel last night when I
went to bed I had two hundred and
ninety-nine thousand subscribers we're
gonna do a quick refresh on there three
hundred thousand and twenty three oh
hello it's all automated wake-up calls
now used to be somebody to talk to
anyway three hundred thousand we hit it
it hasn't really been a goal that I've
been smoking for because a million is
the next goal so 300,000 is really good
to appreciate it love I level of it but
we got to get two million we got to get
two million got to get two million so
happy I could share that moment with you
guys on the vlog because i'm not usually
vlogging when milestones happen so i'm
going to answer a couple more emails see
if I can catch Nina before she's at work
so Nina's on facebook and I asked if she
got my note he said what note she didn't
get my note under the pillow no note oh
they went inside the pillow case oops
how do you make the heart it's not L
anymore alright let's just go pick a
Power Rangers in love alright let's do
that one and start to type and hold the
camera great day love you Nina it's go
time
alright raining like crazy here in New
York City took another film shoots from
New York but luckily my hotel gaming
umbrella but made it here nice hotel
just finished filming an Austin session
breakfast you're talking that we're
going to eat what's for breakfast with
you eggs bacon writing is a funky hotel
by the way lots of fun stuff on the
walls very dimly lit which made it hard
to get a spot but we found it we have to
go to ryans room what's your message to
YouTube everybody come to San Antonio
Texas I love it you want to be on the
show that's what happens breakfast has
arrived I got a pancake with a huge
thing of butter in the middle what do
you got there Ryan today steak and eggs
that's breakfast to stay connected
breakfast things with breakfast which is
American breath oh not a Canadian
breakfast thing maple syrup is
definitely a Canadian breakfast thing
all right just had an awesome breakfast
kind of late breakfast behind super fun
lots of great ideas good motivation
ideas for my business in my channel and
also I think some for his to organism
nice the labs together one super cool
idea that came up as a result of today
that it's very very very excited but I
can't share it yet but it's going to
come soon so I got a little bit of time
before having a hit up for the lunch
take them have to eat lunch and leave
another fan for lunch and then
continuing on with the day
alright i'm here at the restaurant 1250
this is where i need to be for one
o'clock and it's what like 1145 now so
that a little bit of time to kill maybe
do some shopping super can find
something for Nina I gotta buy something
for the wife right I don't need to buy
anything for the wife in New York right
do I need to buy something for the wife
in the air it's any device something for
the wife and New York so she can find
some sexy new york
fellow Canadian youtuber right here love
scene in New York so one of the things
that we talked about over about
breakfast was traveling what would like
to do when we travel and Ryan was saying
that he he's a hermit when he travels he
likes just you know setting up some
meetings but then having some downtime I
mentioned him that when I travel I like
to I like to have meetings I like that
send notes out to my subscribers I like
to meet with them learn about their
business help them out this drives me
nuts at you right now like having this
hour whatever it is to walk around
drives me nuts i'd rather be meeting
with entrepreneurs helping them with
their business is what it is sure as for
you guys when you travel do you like
meeting up with customers do you likely
end up with people who who know you or
do you just like doing your own thing I
think for me it depends if I'm going by
myself or with with family if I'm with
Nina and hate and then I usually don't
set up to any meetings to them us with
time with them but if I'm by myself man
I can I couldn't work at home you know I
want to I can relax whenever I want at
home I want to do stuff I want to meet
people I want to help impact impact is
the goal so what do you guys do you want
to meet customers you want to just do
your own thing let me know in the
comments one of the things that came up
we're talking about book marketing and
getting the tension any ask whether my
goal what was my goal
happy Friday he's asking what my goal
was and I said impact man my goals
impact you've seen if I'm only selling
to my audience then just do a
self-published book you make way more
money it's like my goal isn't money my
goal is impact everything that I do I
want to make an impact and so we said
well that's important because if you're
just trying to make New York Times
bestseller list then those aren't
usually the books well not usually does
not necessarily the books that do well
over a sustained period of time it's
just a bunch of hype at the start and
then they sell a lot of books you could
put on your resume New York Times
bestselling author and then it stopped
selling his first book hit the New York
Times bestseller list but his newer
stuff gotten more traction gotten more
sales had a bigger impact even though it
never hit the seller list because it's
consistent over time and he asked what
my goal is like my goal is always impact
man my goal is impact I don't need to
put New York Times bestselling author on
my website I don't care I have enough to
open doors you know I never wrote a book
defeat the eager to say that I have a
book the goal is impact thank you guys
by the way for that I was feeling a
little upset that I wasn't having an
impact
because we're just walking around New
York City but you know what I just made
an impact recorded a video that's going
to have an impact and just another
reminder for myself whenever you're down
if you want to complain you know you can
always do something always your
responsibility to take control so thank
you guys for letting me do that all
right lunch time meeting with
Christopher okada and he is a newsletter
subscriber he invited me to lunch at a
rooftop although it's raining see how
that goes korean BBQ place and excited
to meet him talk about his business
helps much for nerds it's a good food
and they continue on the day so here we
go call 50 all right in here at a Korean
restaurant down nori with Chris okata
newsletter subscriber fan of the YouTube
channel we got this awesome view here of
New York City and this Chris hey how's
it going guy tell us about your business
real estate developer entrepreneur
trying to start a real estate fund and I
saw Evan on YouTube and shouting out hey
I'm coming New York and I'm going to be
near the Empire State Building so I said
you know what perfect my office is
across the street we owned buildings in
the neighborhood so just wanted to say
what's up to the man right here I love
it give it give us a tip for
entrepreneurs your challenge piece of
advice number one you got to be
passionate about because the truth is
it's a grind it is one hundred percent
of grind there are times when you just
just go home and you know which is
really really tiring and stressful but
that's why you got it that dream has to
be very very strong within you and you
got to have a lot of faith and you got
to surround yourself and with guys that
are mentors and listen to people like
Carmichael over here Craig go on is
youtube and listen to other you know
other entrepreneurs
you know persisted and that's all it is
it's the passion and the persistence and
the people I love what I do and I'm here
a gal nori with Evan to really thank him
and I think it's an honor to that that
we're here and you know the next time
you and your wife or New York definitely
bring her here she'll be very happy so I
love it man fist bump right there boom I
love it all right let's order okay
mushroom japchae noodles and mushrooms
looks good man next that'll I got right
we got my bulgogi I got chicken Oh
chicken checking to the key is staying
healthy yeah we're going to dig in all
right just said by the Chris awesome
dude gave him some advice hopefully help
he asked me what motivated me to do this
like you know why do I spend so much
time doing what I do in helping
entrepreneurs and then meeting up with
people you know I didn't have to meet
with him are going to just not my
business and go but for me
I feel like I covered this earlier today
but you know told him the story and the
time that I spent here needs to be
valuable needs to be useful right then
not meeting with him he better go off
and do great things or I'm going to be
his stop I don't want to waste my time I
hate seeing untapped potential
everywhere like all these people behind
me massive untapped potential even
myself you know I hate wasting my time I
hate wasting my potential and if i'm
here i'm not spending time at home doing
stuff getting work done you know working
on my channel impacting entrepreneurs
everybody doing something pretty darn
important here and yes i had my meeting
with ryan this morning was awesome but i
still have another 12 hours in the day
let's get to work let's do something
let's help some more entrepreneurs so
anyway Chris great guy super excited for
where he's going to go even two great
ideas that I hope you execute on he
promises he will we'll see Chris get to
work buddy and now i'm going to go meet
a bunch of other entrepreneurs at the
starbucks and that's it i'm here for two
more hours and then heading off back to
the airport back home see my wife get a
hug friday night have some fun
alright sitting here NYC starbucks my
last meeting before heading up to the
airport and I'm with some new
entrepreneur friends of mine we're going
to go around the table with quick
introductions
ok my name is we're going on i'm the
founder and director of arts and finance
you might have seen my channel on
youtube also
I'm just here to be open and transparent
a beautiful person hello my name is Gina
I'm inspired i tripping or no
hi my name is mike from New York City
I'm a martial arts school owner an
entrepreneur and I came to me that
veneer with all my friends Carol balsa
sales trainer speaker extraordinaire
straight from the dentist right from the
desert I still be able to speak to you
guys well I appreciate a particular
times to devil bus he gives some tips on
after my name is Orlando Kenya
like oh come on
well my climb verizon that's basically
just in the business of trying to do
some with their lives
love it
i'm spyler
Grundy and she called my channel
nourishing I like that idea we're gonna
get back to work all right in the cab a
super fun meeting they were really
grateful kind of emotional at the end
there really is a heartfelt it's good to
know that when you go you can have an
impact on people that's why I do this
got a little passion excited about it i
think people film the whole chunk of it
so maybe we'll see some guests videos
happening on youtube one awesome thing
at the end mike mike was the guy who has
the martial arts school i mentioned that
i had to go by nina the starbucks cups
because that's what she asked me to get
her and he snuck downstairs and bought
me two that are in here just a super
cool kind of awesome move he didn't have
to do that but kind of went out of his
way to do that and then one of them help
me grab a cab after two I was having a
lot of success and Canadian grabbing
caps though anyway it into the airport
and then flying home to see Nina
all right arrived at the airport in a
little heavy p nauseous I was doing
email on the phone while he was driving
lots of bumps and that national so
trying to chill a little bit check in
about two and a half hours early so have
some time to do stuff and into some
email get on board Air Canada right
behind the Eddie so the flight is
delayed and ghosts and rising
earlier flight
alright so my flight got delayed until 9
45 it is now 6 15 so i have three and a
half hours situated at the airport i'm
not looking good stand by our team lots
of people here lots of people trying to
stay by two so both ways delayed not
fantastic but we'll see got some good
news i got bumped to the earlier flights
from leaving at seven
55 as initiatives whistling would 830 so
I get to go earlier that I was supposed
to have to wait until I thought it was
ten o'clock refer not to the news so
excited Cal Poly sandwiched between two
huge guys who will smell but it doesn't
matter because I'm getting home early I
got online you only get half an hour of
internet here at LaGuardia come on Chico
LaGuardia anyway logs on with my laptop
got old Amina yep I'm happy this is the
happy Evan face excited to go help so on
right at the back of the plane where the
crew was supposed to sit and I'm in the
middle seat but it doesn't matter does
it going home
that was a crazy player so we left late
because there's a crazy storm happen in
New York and every plane coming in and
out of LaGuardia was just crazy busy so
he ended up leaving Polly around the
time that the second flight was supposed
to leave insane turbulence on the way up
insane I almost lost my stomach was
crazy we got next to me between insane
snoring and then when he was awake just
coughing his head off man next level
next level then on the way down we
almost crashed into another plane so
we're heading down and then you hear the
engines go crazy you start taking off
again so that we don't hit the other
plane had to circle around anyway just
nutso but you know what put on a song I
feel better music need to do that and
just going to go through customs and
best part of the chip
well the goal line with the longest ever
craziest flight I got the fastest ever
check out that was not sling off the
plane and literally bright through
customs and done no problems super
excited let's find Inga I see her I see
her I see her I see her she remembered
he remembered hello let me check this
out this is special okay boys in
starbucks understand anything all the
guys the entrepreneurs and then one of
the guys Mike snuck downstairs to go buy
these cups for us okay but one for me
one for you different yeah oh it's just
me open inside different it's a special
cup is every time we drink this we're
gonna think of you you never met them
but you're so like their martial arts
guy
okay thank you for joining at my chip
super short I have to update me on
everything that happened and they're
just going to want to watch the video
anyway alright believe LCC